A point light is what it sounds like. You define a position for it in space and
it gives off light in all directions. You can set the color and intensity just
as you can with directional lights. These lights are different from real world
lights in that by default the distance from the light does not effect its
brightness. Attenuation is not done mostly because it's easier to quickly light
a scene with point lights if there's no drop off with distance. It's entirely
possible to use a different equation for how the light is attenuated by the
distance. For example, you could divide the intensity by the distance or the
distance squared, which is how real lights work, or any other combination. 3JS
supports only one drop-off mode, which is to define a maximum distance. At this
distance, the light goes to zero. This is entirely non-physical, but is useful
for the artistic control of lighting. You can put point lights in a scene and
have each affect a local area without affecting the lighting in other parts of
the scene.